well i'm afraid leon i entirely disagree
with the premise of your question what's
put our public services at risk is
austerity failure to invest and
privatisation particularly of our
nhs now i am an immigrant
i've chosen to become a british citizen
to make my life in britain
i came as a visitor i love the british
way of life i love the traditions the
culture
and i decided to say stay and make this
my home
i went into politics because i want to
improve that i want to protect it and i
want to make sure the vulnerable and our
natural environment are protected
now i live in summerstown in central
london a very diverse community
there are migrants there some of them
are cleaners some of them are doctors
some of them are grandmas
they're all contributing to the british
way of life to the british life in their
own way
now there's someone here on this
platform who wants to utterly demonize
those migrants and you know who i mean
i want to celebrate the contribution of
migrants to britain and i believe we all
should be doing that